I see Thanks I'm gonna fly on a plane
with my two and a half year old daughter
to Virginia without my wife Luanne we're
going on an airplane tomorrow we had a
trip planned to go to Austin Texas one
last trip before our second child
arrives but my grandmother passed away
and I needed to go to Virginia to be
with my family do you think I'll be fine
Kate traveling alone alone on the
airplane it's gonna stay in California
and we're gonna meet up in Austin Texas
for Mother's Day this might be a
disaster gonna see mom in Texas Flynn
could stay with Kate but I really want
Flynn to see my mom and dad and brothers
and sisters I'm Filipino and I really
want Flynn to grow up proud to be
Filipino
all right made it to the airport to got
the car seat in the diaper bag and one
big old bag on my back Flynn seems a
little sad as a kid I was a mama's boy
so I totally sympathized with Flynn
[Music]
while the plane is reaching cruising
altitude were not allowed to use the
seat tray so I kind of hacked together
this way to hold the iPad up but now
Flynn doesn't want to sit in the car
seat anymore
luckily Flynn is taking a nap it's a few
hours past her normal nap time but she's
napping when the plane lands
she's an excitement
he made it to Baltimore and now I got to
get to Norfolk and we got to say the car
seat was an accident
found an arrant smart cart he got
surprised to Flynn we gate check the car
seat and it's a lot less stressful
getting Flynn onto the plane without
having to lug around the car seat Oh
pick your nose
[Music]
we're here in Norfolk hi Daddy Maya
thank you behind you he's scared
now Flynn is pretty shy around my dad
what we call him Lolo Flynn only gets to
see my parents maybe once a year so she
doesn't really know them that well I'm
happy to see ya - Maya you're really
happy very happy it's 10:30 in Norfolk
East Coast time which is 730 California
time
so if Flynn will go up right on time
even though you went to bed a little
late are you hungry
we want to get very good you can't eat a
beer and the memorial for my grandma
isn't until tomorrow but I want to see
my family as much as possible the few
days that were here you're gonna go see
uncle John you're my brother
[Music]
[Music]
so I called up my mom two weeks ago to
wish her a happy birthday and it was
that day that I found out that my
grandma was on her deathbed my mom was
staying beside her all night just to be
around in case she passed
so everyone's coming over to where Flynn
and I are staying for dinner and Flynn's
cousins and my older brother are there
and they get to hang out hi Uncle Mark
Flynn's pretty shy around her cousins at
first but it doesn't take her long to
hold their hands and have fun pretty
soon a lot of my family comes over
including my younger sister Anna who I
haven't seen in a while
it's definitely crowded and it reminds
me a lot of growing up
we weren't surrounded by a large
Filipino community so my family were the
Filipinos that I knew as a kid and being
of a different culture
it could be lonely it can be kind of
scary when people become hostile so I
always felt safe around my family and
you know I want Flynn to have that same
comfort I wish we could do this more
often you're kind of tossing and turning
but you got to sleep you might see your
cousin the whole trip started out pretty
stressful but I've adapted Flynn has
adapted we both miss cave but you know
we're having a pretty good time
today's my grandmother's memorial and
Flynn gets to hang out with her cousins
some more my grandma is to call my
siblings and I her little branches and I
guess Flynn is you know an extension of
that my grandma my grandpa used to play
music together Flynn gets to experience
you know us being musical together and
having a good time giving her that
exposure to the Filipino side of my
family is really important to me I think
I'm finally able to process the fact
that my grandma's just not in this world
anymore
[Music]
it's Mother's Day and my brothers and
sisters and my mom and dad and Flynn's
cousins get to come with us to the
airport send us off I'm glad I got to
tell my mom happy Mother's Day it does
feel different you know with my grandma
guy like my mom's the new matriarch I've
had a lot of fun was just Flynn and I
I'm so happy that Flynn got to hang out
with my family she's gonna miss her
cousins a lot but she also misses Kate a
lot and I do too so that's gonna be
really awesome to see Kate and wish her
a Happy Mother's Day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]